PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BORDER
POLICIES BEING BLAMED FOR A
HORRIFIC LOSS OF LIFE IN TEXAS.
AT LEAST 51 MIGRANTS FOUND DEALT
FROM THE SWELTERS HEAT STACKED
ON TOP OF ONE ANOTHER IN AN
ABANDONED TRACTOR TRAILER THAT
HAD NO AIR CONDITIONING OR
WATER.
IT WAS ONE OF THE DEADLIEST
INCIDENTS OF SMUGGLING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THERE'S BEEN RECORD NUMBERS
ACROSS THE BORDER.
AGENTS SAY THEY'RE OVERWHELMED
BY THE SURGE AND DON'T FEEL
SUPPORTED.
GREG ABBOTT TWEETING THIS.
THESE DEATHS ARE ON BIDEN.
THEY ARE A RESULT OF HIS DEADLY
OPEN BORDER POLICIES.
SENATOR TED CRUZ TWEETING HOW
MANY MORE PEOPLE HAVE TO DIE
BEFORE DEMS GIVE A DAMN?
THE WHITE HOUSE FIRING BACK AT
CRITICS.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE
BORDER IS CLOSED, WHICH IS IN
PART WHY YOU SEE PEOPLE TRYING
TO MAKE THIS DANGEROUS JOURNEY
USING SMUGGLING NETWORKS.
WE'RE GOING TO STAY FOCUSED ON
THE FACTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE HOLD THESE SMUGGLERS
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Dana: JESSE, IS IT FAIR TO
BLAME PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
POLICIES?
>> Jesse: I BELIEVE IT IS FAIR.
HE'S A SNOB FROM DELAWARE.
HE DOESN'T CONSIDER TEXAS A PART
OF THE COUNTRY.
HE THINKS IT'S OUR GAS STATION.
THAT'S WHERE THEY KILLED KEEP
DID, KILLED THE OZONE LAYER AND
THEY'RE NEANDERTHALS.
THAT'S HOW HE FEELS ABOUT TEXAS.
HE'S BEEN TO CHINA MORE THAN OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
I DON'T FEELS LIKE HE FEELS
GREAT AFFECTION TO THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
IT'S A MASS CASUALTY OF 40
MEXICAN NATIONALS ARE DEAD.
>> Dana: 51.
>> Jesse: 51.
IF THAT WAS JAPANESE, BRITISH
NAN  -- NATIONALS, HE WOULD BE
ON THE FORDER.
AOC FLEW DOWN THE FLY ON A FENCE
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP PUT ADULTS
AND CHILDREN IN SEPARATE
FACILITIES.
NOW AOC DOES NOTHING.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T ASK JOE BIDEN
ABOUT THE BORDER.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T COVER IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO GO
DOWN THERE, IT'S HARD TO GET TO,
HOT AND DUSTY AND IT'S NOT
GLAMOROUS TO DO STANDUPS DOWN
THERE.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE IT DOESN'T
EXIST.
HERE'S THE SOLUTION.
WE HAVE TO BRING ALL OF THE
FACTORIES THAT WE HAVE IN CHINA
AND PUT THEM IN NORTH MEXICO.
WE HAVE A TRADE DEAL WITH
MEXICO.
THAT'S WHERE THEIR JOBS WILL BE.
IT SOLVES THE CHINA PROBLEM,
SOLVES THE IMMIGRATION PROBLEM.
PUT THE FACTORIES IN COLUMBIA,
TOO.
WE HAVE A TRADE PACT WITH THE
COLUMBIANS AS WELL.
I THINK THAT SOLVES ALL THE
PROBLEMS.
HE SHOULD DO THAT.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SECURITY
THE BORDER AND IF YOU'RE GOING
TO THROW MONEY AT A CORRUPT
HONDURAN PRESIDENT --
>> Dana: I'D LIKE MORE ON THE
PROSECUTION OF THE SUSPECTS
ALREADY APPREHENDED.
THEY HAVE THREE PEOPLE THERE.
OBVIOUSLY A CHAIN THAT GOES ALL
THE WAY BACK.
>> Jeanine: WHAT YOU DO IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT -- GOT BLESS
CALIFORNIA.
THEY LET THESE GUY GOES AS SOON
AS THEY ARRESTED THEM.
THEY HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION ON
FENTANYL.
THEY CAN GIVE YOU NO, SIR
WHETHER IT'S HUMAN SMUGGLING,
DRUG SMUGGLING.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
YOU GO UP THE CHAIN.
YOU SCARE THEM, YOU SCARE THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE FEDS DO IT EVERY DAY.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU SOMETHING, IN
A BIZARRE WAY, I THINK I THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION COULD TURN
THIS THING AROUND AND SAY SEE,
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
WE TOLD YOU THE BORDER IS
SECURED.
SEE, THEY HAVE TO SMUGGLE THEM
IN LIKE THIS.
THEY'RE DIEING TO COME IN.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE THAT
CONTRADICTS ALL OF THAT.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT FIGHTING
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
HE DOESN'T WANT THE ILLEGALS TO
REMAIN IN MEXICO.
HE'S TITLE 42.
HE WANTS TO OPEN THE BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD FAULT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT BECAUSE HE WAS
INSPECTING THE 18 WHEELERS AS HE
CAME IN.
EVERYBODY BROUGHT CRITICISM IN
SAYING HE WAS CLOGGING UP
TRAFFIC.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT COULD HAVE
FOUGHT HIM.
NO, WE HAD TO STOP HIM.
SO WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING IS THEY'RE LAYING OUT THE
WELCOME MAT EVERY DRAY IN TERMS
OF WHAT THEY DO.
THEY CAN TELL ME UNTIL THE COWS
COME HOME, THE BORDER IS SECURE,
THE BORDER IS CLOSED AND THEY'RE
LYING TO ALL OF US.
THEY'RE BUSY FLYING THEM IN,
BUSSING THEM IN TO THE INTERIOR,
THEY'RE HOUSING UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR CHILDREN SMUGGLED IN BY
THE CARTELS THAT THEY'RE
ACCOMPANYING AND FACILITATING
HIRING 800 AMERICANS TO STAFF A
FACILITY.
QUIETLY ERASING IMMIGRATION
CASES GIVING AMNESTY TO ONE
MILLION ILLEGALS.
THE GOAL FOR THEM SHOULD BE TO
STOP THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
THE DRUG SMUGGLING.
THEY'RE DOING JUST THE OPPOSITE.
SO WHY IS HE TRY SO HARD TO
FAIL?
WHY IS IT THAT HE LET IT GET
THIS WAY?
IS HE THAT AFRAID OF THE
PROGRESSIVES?
WHY?
>> Dana: GERALDO, TAKE IT FROM
THERE.
>> I TOTALLY -- I WANT TO SAY
IT'S SO EASY FOR SENATOR CRUZ OR
GOVERNOR ABBOTT TO SAY OH,
BIDEN'S FAULT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER FIRST OF
ALL, LET ME EXPRESS SINCERE
CONDOLENCE
CONDOLENCES, I FEEL GRIEF OVER
THIS MASS MURDER.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS, A MASS
MURDER.
I'M OUTRAGED AT THESE
PERPETRATORS.
I WANT THEM PROSECUTED.
THE JUDGE IS RIGHT, YOU SQUEEZE
THEM, WALK YOUR WAY UP THE
TRAIN.
MAYBE YOU CAN GET THE MEXICANS
INVOLVED.
WE CANNOT ABIDE 51 MURDERS.
I BLAME PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I THINK HIS COMPASSION HAS
BACKFIRED AT THE BORDER.
I THINK IT'S OBNOXIOUS AS TRUMPS
MOVES WERE.
I THINK AS WE APPROACH JULY 4th,
WE WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE IS THE
BRUTALITY OF THIS EVIDENCE OF
HOW BADLY THESE PEOPLE WANT TO
BE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THEY RISK EVERYTHING.
EVEN THEIR VERY LIVES.
THEY VOLUNTARILY STUFFED
THEMSELVES IN TO THAT SEMI ONLY
TO CHOKE THEMSELVES ON SWELTERS
HEAT.
>> Dana: I WAS TALKING TO BILL
MELUGIN NOT LONG AGO.
HE SEE NOTICE OTHER REPORTERS
THERE.
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR MONTHS.
I WATCH ONE NIGHTLY NEWS
BROADCAST EVERY NIGHT.
I NEVER SEE ANY COVERAGE OF THE
BORDER, THIS STORY THEY WOULD
COVER.
>> YOU HAVE TO COVER THIS STORY.
SADLY OBVIOUSLY IT'S
DEVASTATING.
NOT THAT IS SURPRISING.
IT'S A COMPLETE DISASTER DOWN
THERE.
IT'S A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
ANYBODY PAYING ATTENTION TO
IMMIGRATION AT ALL KNOWS THAT.
ALSO SUCH A DISASTER WHEN THEY
SAID SEE, LOOK, THE BORDER IS
CLOSED.
THE PROVES IT'S CLOSED.
I WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW THAT UP
WITH BEING, OKAY, DOES THIS LOOK
GOOD?
IS IT GOING WELL?
NOTHING IN TERMS OF THE
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS GOING
WELL, INCLUDING LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
YOU TALK ANT PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND GET
WORK VISAS AND GO THE LEGAL WAY.
THEY WASTED 66,000 OF THOSE
VISAS DESPITE THE LABOR MARKET
WAS SO TIGHT THAT ARE EXPIRED
AND THEY CAN NEVER GO BACK.
THE WHOLE SYSTEM IS A COMPLETE
DISASTER AND THEY'RE SCRAMBLING.
ANYONE PAYING ATTENTION, THEY
CAN FIGURE THA